This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the late 1800s, as more and more people began to have electric lights in their homes, the utility companies began looking for a good way to measure how much electricity each customer was using. Actually, way back when Thomas Edison built the first electric power stations, there were no electric meters in people's homes, so he built a monthly fee based on how many light bulbs they had. That Sam Evans Brown of New Hampshire Public Radio. That building per light bulb system wasn't great, so people came up with a meter that did the job well enough. It's the same basic meter that most of us in the US have in our homes today.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在19世纪后期，随着越来越多的人开始在家里使用电灯，公用事业公司开始寻找一种好方法来计量每个客户使用了多少电。事实上，早在托马斯·爱迪生建造第一个发电厂时，人们家里并没有电表，因此他根据他们拥有的灯泡数量来收取月费。那是新罕布什尔公共广播电台的萨姆·埃文斯·布朗。那种按灯泡收费的系统并不好，所以人们发明了一种电表，能够很好地完成这项工作。这就是今天我们大多数美国人家里都有的基本电表。
And the way it works is when the electricity comes into your house, a little dial turns forward and shows how much you've used. And even though the original designers never really intended for this to happen, if you send electricity back into the grid, the dial turns backward to show electricity leaving your house. Now, if you're like me, there's no electricity leaving your house. It's only coming in. But if you're like Sam, who has solar panels on his roof, electricity is leaving your house. It's only coming in. But if you're like Sam who has solar panels on his roof electricity is leaving the house and going back into the grid. Yeah That's because my solar panels create more energy than I can use that excess energy goes back into the grid and Out to my neighbors and in my state New Hampshire, I get credited for that extra energy I create
它的工作原理是，当电进入你家时，一个小表盘会向前转动，显示你用了多少电。尽管最初的设计者从未真正打算让它这样做，但如果你把电送回电网，表盘就会向后转动，显示电正在离开你的家。现在，如果你像我一样，没有任何电离开你的家，它只会进来。但是，如果你像萨姆那样，屋顶上有太阳能电池板，电就会离开你的家。它只会进来。但是，如果你像萨姆那样，屋顶上有太阳能电池板，电就会离开房屋并流回电网。是的。那是由于我的太阳能电池板产生的能量超过了我能使用的量，多余的能量会流回电网并输送给我的邻居，而在我的家乡新罕布什尔州，我因此类额外产生的能量而获得信用额度。
It's a practice called net metering and for a while It was totally not Controversial, but now it is there are huge political battles being fought over this Sam and his colleagues at New Hampshire public radio actually did a whole episode of their podcast outside in about net metering because They are even Nurtier than we are and I'm just going to hand it off to them now. So here's Sam and in a little bit you'll hear the voices of his colleagues, Maureen McMurray and Taylor Quimby.
这是一种被称为净计量电价的做法，有一段时间它完全没有争议，但现在有了，围绕这个话题正在展开巨大的政治斗争。萨姆和他在新罕布什尔公共广播电台的同事们实际上为他们的播客节目《外在》制作了一整集关于净计量电价的节目，因为他们比我们还要书呆子气，现在我打算把它交由他们来讲述。所以，这是萨姆，过一会儿你还会听到他的同事莫琳·麦克默里和泰勒·奎姆比的声音。
So before we get into the controversy over net metering, I want to go back and introduce you to the guy who accidentally started it all. His name is Steven Strong. Sun energy, the license plate, appropriately. Oh, and then we've got plug in. So like me, Steven is an energy nerd. He's a guy who, when Toyota came out with a Prius, he got his engineers to hack the thing. Gosh.
因此，在我们深入探讨有关净计量电价的争议之前，我想先带大家认识一下这位不小心开启这一切的人。他的名字叫史蒂芬·斯特朗。车牌也很应景，叫“太阳能”。哦，还有插电式。所以，就像我一样，史蒂芬是一个能源书呆子。当丰田推出普锐斯时，他是那种会叫工程师去对其进行改装的人。天哪。
All right, so can you describe what we're looking at here? This is a lithium ion battery pack that's shoehorned into the spare tire. So he and his engineers made a plug-in Prius and that it years before the car company. And also Toyota went bananas when we told them we were doing this. So way back before he started messing around with Priuses, Steven founded a company called Solar Design Associates. This was at a time when solar power, besides being something on satellites in outer space, wasn't really a thing yet.
好吧，那么你能描述一下我们在这里看到的是什么吗？这是一个塞进备胎里的锂离子电池组。所以他和他的工程师们制造了一辆插电式普锐斯，而且比汽车公司早了好几年。而且当我们告诉丰田我们在这样做时，他们简直快气疯了。所以，早在开始摆弄普锐斯之前，史蒂芬就创立了一家名为太阳能设计合资公司的企业。那时的太阳能，除了是外太空卫星上的东西之外，还算不上什么真正的民用技术。
And when was this again? Is this the 70s? Yeah, mid 70s. It was a heck of a hard way to make Kinesi living in the 70s and the 80s and the 90s. So Steven's strong is this hard charging, ready to drop everything and get his hands dirty kind of guy, and he kicked off what eventually became kind of a revolution in the way a lot of people are getting their energy. He did it by putting solar panels on an apartment building for people with modest incomes.
这又是什么时候的事？这是70年代吗？是的，70年代中期。在70年代、80年代和90年代，要靠这个过上体面的生活简直难如登天。所以史蒂芬·斯特朗就是那种充满冲劲、随时准备放下一切并亲自动手的人，他开启了后来成为许多人获取能源方式的一场革命。他通过在一个为中低收入人群建造的公寓楼上安装太阳能电池板来实现这一点。
There it is, that's the building here. Oh, it's huge. Now, this is huge, but why? Bernie's. Bernie's wide, huge. So this building looks kind of like a big college dorm. It's brick and pretty unremarkable. I think we're not supposed to drive this way.
就是那个，这就是那栋建筑。哦，它很大。现在，这个很大，但为什么呢？伯尼的。伯尼的宽，巨大。所以这栋建筑看起来有点像一个大型大学宿舍。它是砖砌的，非常普通。我想我们不应该走这条路。
Well, that's the story of my life. But when it was built on its roof, there was this massive array of solar panels, one of the first of its kind. This was one of the largest solar thermal systems in New England, and it met something like 80% of the annual hot water requirements. But this was like the early days of solar, so this is solar thermal, it's just like heating hot water, it didn't make electricity.
好吧，这就是我的人生写照。但当它建成时，其屋顶上有着极其庞大的太阳能电池板阵列，是同类产品中的首批之一。这是新罕布什尔州最大的太阳能热利用系统之一，它满足了大约80%的年度热水需求。但这就像是太阳能的早期阶段，所以这是太阳能热利用，它就像是加热热水，它不发电。
It's a solar thermal, it uses solar panels, but all it does is heat up hot water, and that was cool. Solar thermal is like the simplest technology on the planet. It's so simple. It's got this big box, and on the inside, you've got some tubes that are colored black, and you put water in it, or some sort of coolant
这是一种太阳能热利用，它使用太阳能电池板，但它所做的全部事情就是加热热水，这很酷。太阳能热利用就像是地球上最简单的技术。它是如此简单。它有一个大箱子，里面有一些涂成黑色的管子，你在里面装水，或者某种冷却剂。
or refrigerant in there, and the sun shines on the black tubes and heats it up, and then you can circulate that back into a tank, and that's all it was. That's, I feel like I could come up with that. I feel like that's like on the level of technology wise of like using a magnifying glass to like set a pizza paper on fire. Wait, the solar panels that Carter put on the White House
或者里面的制冷剂，阳光照射在黑色的管子上并将其加热，然后你可以将它循环回储水箱，这就是它的全部内容。就是这样，我觉得我也能想出那个点子。我觉得这就好比用放大镜点燃一张披萨纸那样的技术水平。等等，卡特放在白宫的那些太阳能电池板。
were those the solar thermal ones? Yeah. That was stupid. He was just heating water at the White House? Yeah. In any case, it was mostly solar thermal panels up there, but Steven Strong convinced the developer to let him install a couple of solar photovoltaic panels too.
那些是太阳能热利用板吗？是的。那太蠢了。他只是在白宫加热水吗？是的。无论如何，那上面大多是太阳能热利用板，但史蒂芬·斯特朗说服开发商也让他安装了几块太阳能光伏板。
Photovoltaic panels are the ones that actually make electricity, and at that time there were a brand new technology. Now as soon as the technology was available, we were employing it. But there was this question, how should I do the wiring? Wait, what do you mean? So whenever the sun is shining, obviously the electricity will go towards running all the stuff in the building, you know, water pumps, hot water heaters, whatever.
光伏板是那些实际发电的板，在当时它们是一项全新技术。现在，只要技术一可用，我们就在采用它。但当时有一个问题，我应该如何布线？等等，你是什么意思？所以，每当阳光普照时，显然电会流向运行建筑物里的所有东西，你知道的，水泵、热水器，等等。
But what happens when the sun's not shining? Or what happens if the sun is shining and there's nothing going on in the building? So what he decided to do was just configure it so that when there's no sun, the building would work just like any other building. It would buy electricity from the utility company and the little dials on the electric meter
但是当没有阳光时会发生什么？或者如果阳光灿烂而大楼里没有任何用电需求时会发生什么？所以他决定这样配置：当没有阳光时，这栋建筑的运作方式将与其他任何建筑完全一样。它将向公用事业公司购电，电表上的小表盘。
would roll forward. Five kilowatt hours, 10 kilowatt hours, 20, 30, 40, 50. I don't know what a watt. It's a lot of money. Oh my God, a lot of money. You don't have to know what a watt is or what a A lot of money. You don't have to know what a watt is, or what a kilowatt hour is. You don't have to know. All you need to know is that it's the measurement for electricity use.
会向前滚动。5千瓦时，10千瓦时，20，30，40，50。我不知道瓦是什么。那是一大笔钱。哦，天哪，一大笔钱。你不需要知道瓦是什么，或者。一大笔钱。你不需要知道瓦是什么，或者千瓦时是什么。你不需要知道。你只需要知道它是用电量的计量单位。
So getting back to Steven Solar panels, what he did that no one had ever done before was to wire it up so that if the sun was shining and the building wasn't using any energy, the unused electricity would flow out into the grid, and the little dial on the meter would just roll in the other direction, backwards. 50, 40, 30, 20, 10. Which means, at the end of the month, when the person comes to check the meter,
所以回到史蒂芬的太阳能电池板，他所做的前无古人的事情是进行了电路改造，这样如果阳光普照而大楼没有消耗任何能量，未使用的电力就会流入电网，电表上的小表盘就会朝另一个方向滚动，也就是向后。50，40，30，20，10。这意味着，在一个月底，当有人来检查电表时。
the owners of the building would pay for whatever the dial said. So, like, if they used 60 kilowatt hours, but they put in 40, the dial would say 20, and they would only pay for 20. And it worked. It was just, it was intuitive. It was almost like that's just a way it should be. It's like we're producing electrons that are just as valuable as the ones provided by the coal plant or the heavy residual fuel oil driven plant. Why shouldn't they receive the same value? And so it just made sense. Did you talk to the utility at all?
建筑物的业主只需为表盘显示的数字付费。所以，比如说，如果他们用了60千瓦时，但他们输入了40千瓦时，表盘就会显示20，他们只需要支付20的费用。而且它奏效了。它就是、它很直观。这几乎就像这本该就是应有的方式。这就好比我们生产的电子与煤炭发电厂或重油发电厂提供的电子具有相同的价值。为什么它们不应该获得相同的价值呢？所以这完全说得通。你跟公用事业公司沟通过吗？
Did you show them your design and say this is what we're going to do? No. The developers said, you don't worry about that. You just get the technical side of this done and get it working. And we'll take care that we're going to be interfacing with the utility. It turned out that they didn't say anything about the system to the utility purposefully. And told me at the time, there's one thing in your career that you should learn early and that is it's easier to ask forgiveness than it is to ask permission. and that is it's easier to ask forgiveness than it is to ask permission.
你把你的设计展示给他们看并说这就是我们要做的吗？没有。开发商说，你不用担心那个。你只管把技术方面的事情搞定并让它运转起来。我们会处理好与公用事业公司的接口问题的。事实证明，他们故意没有向公用事业公司透露有关该系统的任何信息。并且当时告诉我，在你职业生涯中有一件事你应该早点学会，那就是请求原谅比请求许可更容易。并且当时告诉我，在你职业生涯中有一件事你应该早点学会，那就是请求原谅比请求许可更容易。
And that, ladies and gentlemen, is how we got a little policy called net metering. Is that true? So why wouldn't he tell them? Well, it's uncharted waters. He didn't know what the utility would say, and he didn't want to be told no. So net metering, it's the net of when the meter goes forward and goes backward. It's what's in between. Yeah, net as in net versus gross. I mean, the only reason that it was designed that way is because that is what the meter could do. You know, that little spinning disc electric meter, all it can do is spin forward and backwards. So that's what they used. But it was well and truly the first one that was connected to the utility grid outside the fence of a government laboratory.
女士们先生们，这就是我们如何获得一项名为净计量电价的小政策的方式。真的吗？那他为什么不告诉他们呢？嗯，这是未知的领域。他不知道公用事业公司会说些什么，他也不想被拒绝。因此，净计量电价，就是电表向前走和向后走的净差额。这就是中间的部分。是的，这里的“净”是指净额与总额的对比。我的意思是，它之所以这样设计，唯一的原因是因为那是电表能够做到的事情。你知道的，那个带旋转盘的电表，它能做的全部事情就是向前和向后旋转。这就是他们所使用的。但它确实是地地道道连接到政府实验室围栏之外的公用事业电网的第一套系统。
Okay, so he puts in the solar panels on the roof of this building, what happens? So the utility company, they were actually fine with the whole thing. In fact, they praised Stephen's innovation, but the solar panels didn't last very long. They actually blew off the building in the first year. And they didn't like, they didn't glue them on or whatever.
好吧，所以他在这个建筑物的屋顶上安装了太阳能电池板，接下来发生了什么？所以公用事业公司，他们其实对整件事情持接受态度。事实上，他们称赞了史蒂芬的创新，但太阳能电池板并没有维持多久。在第一年里，它们实际上就被大风从楼顶吹掉了。而且他们没有，他们没有用胶水把它们粘上去或者别的什么。
It's not the truth, it's against windy. So not a terribly auspicious start, but what it did was kick off some intense interest in this idea that solar could serve the needs of a home, but also produce electricity for the grid like a tiny part-time power plant. And this concept of homeowner as power plants is actually important in thinking about how people with solar panels on their homes will be paid for the power they're producing. Because big established power plants sell power to the utility companies at a cheaper wholesale cost. And then the utility companies can sell their customers that power at a cheaper wholesale cost. And then the utility companies can sell their customers that power at a higher retail rate
这不是事实，它风太大了。所以这算不上是一个非常吉利的开始，但它所做的是激起了人们对这样一种想法的强烈兴趣：太阳能既可以满足家庭的需求，也可以像一个微型的兼职发电厂一样为电网产生电力。而这种将房主视为发电厂的概念，对于思考屋顶装有太阳能电池板的人们将如何获得他们所产电力的报酬至关重要。因为大型老牌发电厂以较低的批发成本向公用事业公司出售电力。然后公用事业公司可以以较低的批发成本向客户出售这些电力。然后公用事业公司可以以更高的零售价向客户出售这些电力。
so that they can make profit and pay for their costs. So then the question becomes, do people with solar panels, do they become like the mini power plants? Should they be paid the lower wholesale rate or the higher retail rate? So are they like Costco or are they like mom and pop? Is that what is that
这样他们就可以获利并支付成本。于是问题就变成了，拥有太阳能电池板的人，他们是否变成了微型发电厂？他们应该获得较低的批发价还是较高的零售价？所以他们是像好市多（Costco）还是像夫妻小店？这就是那个，是那个。
that I know this analogy? I think that's pretty good. In any case, states eventually started passing laws about this very question. And that was all through the 80s and the 90s. And for the most part, these laws said that the utility companies should pay people the higher retail rate because it's expensive to put solar panels on your house, and this would incentivize solar. And eventually, 41 states passed laws allowing people to get this higher retail rate
我知道这个类比吗？我觉得这挺恰当的。无论如何，各州最终开始围绕这个确切的问题通过法律。这一切都贯穿于80年代和90年代。在大多数情况下，这些法律规定公用事业公司应该向人们支付较高的零售价，因为在房子上安装太阳能电池板成本很高，而这将激励太阳能的发展。最终，有41个州通过了法律，允许人们获得这个较高的零售价。
for net metering, and utility companies, at the time, they didn't put up much of a fight about it. Yeah, but the utility companies, at this point, they're like dancing with the devil, and they don't even realize it. Yeah, and nobody had any reason to say, oh, this might not be a good idea because solar was just like this weird thing
用于净计量电价，而公用事业公司当时并没有对此进行太大的抗争。是的，但是公用事业公司，在这一点上，他们就像是在与魔鬼共舞，而他们甚至没有意识到这一点。是的，而且没有人有任何理由去说，哦，这可能不是一个好想法，因为太阳能就像是一个奇怪的东西。
that probably was never gonna be cost effective. And that's how it was for a bunch of years. Until suddenly, solar started to get cheap. For decades, solar power was so expensive and unwieldy if you could afford it. And that is changing in a mind-bendingly rapid pace. Solar-related stocks rallied on Wednesday on the news that Congress plans to extend
它可能永远不会具有成本效益。多年来一直如此。直到突然之间，太阳能开始变得便宜了。几十年来，如果你买得起的话，太阳能电力是如此昂贵且笨重。而这种状况正以令人眼花缭乱的极快速度发生改变。周三，受国会计划延长利好消息的推动，太阳能相关股票出现反弹。
a solar investment tax credit by five years. Starting the mid-2000s, a bunch of really ambitious, well-financed companies start saying, hey, we can make some money doing this. And so from 2009 to 2010, the amount of solar in the US doubled. It doubled again from 2010 to 2011. It doubled again from 2011 to 2013. And from 2013 to today, it's on track to triple again.
太阳能投资税收信用五年。从2000年中期开始，一群雄心勃勃、资金充足的公司开始说，嘿，我们可以通过做这个赚点钱。因此，从2009年到2010年，美国的太阳能总量翻了一番。从2010年到2011年又翻了一番。从2011年到2013年再次翻了一番。而从2013年到今天，它有望再次翻三番。
Okay, so what are these companies doing that's different? Like how are they making money? What's their model? What they're doing is they're offering people solar for no money down. They pay for the cost of the panels and exchange, they take a chunk of the money that you would earn by producing power. And so if you had someone come and knock on your door and say, hey, want to be part of the next renewable energy era, and you could have solar panels on your roof right now, and it's not going to cost you any money, and we're going to give you a discount on your power bill. I'd say, yeah. And that business model is made possible by net metering, by getting this higher retail
好吧，那么这些公司在做什么不同的事情呢？比如他们是怎么赚钱的？他们的模式是什么？他们在做的是向人们提供零首付的太阳能。他们支付电池板的成本，作为回报，他们拿走你通过发电所赚取的一部分钱。所以，如果有人来敲你的门说，嘿，想成为下一个可再生能源时代的一部分吗？你现在就可以在屋顶上安装太阳能电池板，而且不需要花你一分钱，我们还将给你的电费打折。我会说，好的。这种商业模式之所以能够实现，是因为净计量电价，即获得了更高的零售价。
rate for the power people are producing with solar. And I think it's fair to say that the utility companies basically did not see this coming. And so now, they're starting to push back. They don't want to be paying the retail rate. They think people generating electricity with solar should get the wholesale rate, just like a power plant would. So where the fights happening now then? Where the really high profile fights over net metering? Well, so obviously Arizona is the number one. So that's Kristi Schalenberger, who works for this industry news site called Utility Die that tracks all this stuff.
人们用太阳能发电的价格。我认为公平地说，公用事业公司基本上没有预见到这一点。所以现在，他们开始进行反击。他们不想支付零售价。他们认为通过太阳能发电的人应该获得批发价，就像发电厂一样。那么现在战斗在哪里发生呢？关于净计量电价的高调斗争在哪里？好吧，很显然亚利桑那州是头号阵地。那是克里斯蒂·沙伦伯格，她为一家名为“公用事业内幕”的行业新闻网站工作，该网站追踪所有这些事情。
She points out that we've seen net metering battles in California. And of course you have Nevada, which has basically become the by word for what you don't want to see. Nevada's fight got really crazy. Huge, huge blowback from all swaths of life. Basically, you have celebrities, you have presidential candidates. I do not often get involved in state or local issues other than my own state, but I find it rather incredible that the Public Utilities Commission here in Nevada has made a decision which makes it harder for people to
她指出我们在加利福尼亚州看到了净计量电价之争。当然还有内华达州，它基本上成了你不愿意见到的典型代名词。内华达州的斗争变得异常疯狂。来自各行各业的巨大、巨大的强烈反弹。基本上，你有名人，有总统候选人。除了我自己的州之外，我通常不会参与州或地方事务，但我发现内华达州的公共公用事业委员会做出了这样一个决定，这真是令人难以置信。
install solar panels. Wait, who is that? That was Bernie Sanders. You're joking. But anyway, you've got this crazy obscure policy that's getting tons of attention. Hillary Clinton talked about it when she went to Nevada and talked to local newspapers there. There are fights in Iowa, Texas, Maine, Vermont, New York, Utah, Hawaii, and of course, right here in New Hampshire.
让人们变得更难。安装太阳能电池板。等等，那是谁？那是伯尼·桑德斯。你在开玩笑吧。但无论如何，你有一个疯狂而鲜为人知的政策，却获得了大量的关注。希拉里·克林顿去内华达州并与当地报纸交谈时也谈到了这一点。爱荷华州、得克萨斯州、缅因州、佛蒙特州、纽约州、犹他州、夏威夷州，当然还有我们这里的新罕布什尔州，都有这样的争斗。
It's a battle that's happening all over the country, state by state, the local electric companies pushing back and all the solar installers fighting against the utilities, and each state has like its own local flavor to this argument. But I still don't understand a little bit about this fight. Like, why would me having solar panels on my roof? Why would it make the utility company like so angry? Is it just money? Well, yeah, of course it's about money, but who's money? The utility companies want to reframe this argument so that it's not just about their interests, but it's about the interests of the people
这是全国各地都在发生的一场战斗，一个州接一个州，当地的电力公司在反击，而所有的太阳能安装商都在与公用事业公司抗争，每个州对这个争论都有其独特的本地特色。但我仍然不太理解这场斗争的一些地方。比如，为什么我在屋顶上安装太阳能电池板？为什么这会让公用事业公司如此愤怒？这只是为了钱吗？嗯，是的，这当然是关于钱，但那是谁的钱？公用事业公司想要重新构建这个论点，使其不仅仅关乎他们的利益，而是关乎那些人的利益。
who don't have solar panels. So, okay, here I talk to Michael Harrington, who, here in New Hampshire, he used to be one of the guys who regulates electric companies. It's a taking from the not so people that have not so much and giving it to people have more. Say I was retired school teacher in Manchester living in an apartment, there's no way I'm going to put solar panels on that apartment roof
没有太阳能电池板的人。好吧，在这里我采访了迈克尔·哈灵顿，在新罕布什尔州，他以前是监管电力公司的人员之一。这是从没有那么多钱的人那里拿走，然后给那些拥有更多的人。假设我是曼彻斯特的一名退休学校教师，住在一间公寓里，我绝不可能在那栋公寓屋顶上安装太阳能电池板。
and get any benefit from that metering but I'm going to have to pay for it because some guy in Bedford, I just use Bedford as an example, I've got nothing to do with Bedford. Bedford, if you're not from New Hampshire, is a wealthy suburb of Manchester, which is our biggest city. But he might have a 4,000 square foot house, and he says, boy, if I do this net metering thing in five or six years, I'll be getting basically free electricity. So it's a reverse distribution of wealth from the way we normally do things in the United States.
并从净计量电价中获得任何好处，但我却不得不为此买单，因为贝德福德的某个人——我只是用贝德福德作为例子，我跟贝德福德没有任何关系。如果你不是新罕布什尔州人，贝德福德是曼彻斯特的一个富裕郊区，而曼彻斯特是我们最大的城市。但他可能有一栋4000平方英尺的房子，他说，天哪，如果我做这个净计量电价的事情，在五六年内，我基本上就能获得免费电力。所以这是对我们美国通常做法的一种财富逆向分配。
And I don't think that's right. Hmm. I get it. So it's like someone ultimately has to pay and if all of these people who are people of means who are homeowners have solar panels, then the cost of the other utility will go up. And that means that people who are renting or anything like that, they get screwed because I want solar panels on my house.
我觉得这不对。嗯。我明白了。所以这就像最终总得有人付钱，如果所有这些有钱的房主都有太阳能电池板，那么其他公用事业的成本就会上升诸如此类。这意味着租房者或类似的人会吃亏，因为我想在我的房子上安装太阳能电池板。
And that's me. This is how rate structures work, right? A utility is a big company that invests a ton of money in polls and wires, in energy descent across those polls and wires, and then they take all of their customers and they divide the cost of that up between all of them and they spread it around. And under that business model, if say 50% of the people in the US went solar and started that metering, a big chunk of the money that they're saving is money that's not going towards paying for the polls and wires. So this is the argument against net metering, which is you, or let's say me, because I actually do have solar panels on my roof right?
这就是我。这就是费率结构运作的方式，对吧？公用事业是一家大公司，在电线杆和电线上投资了大量资金，将能量跨越这些电线杆和电线传输，然后他们拿走所有的客户，把成本分摊到所有人身上并将其散布开来。在这种商业模式下，假设美国50%的人改用太阳能并开始净计量电价，他们省下的很大一部分钱是没有用于支付电线杆和电线的钱。所以这就是反对净计量电价的论点，也就是你，或者我们假设是我，因为我确实在屋顶上有太阳能电池板，对吧？
So you're screwing me because I don't. I'm screwing you. Yeah, me putting solar panels on my roof costs you money. What the hell, Sam? What the hell, Sam? Except the problem is we're not 100% sure that's true. Hold on a second. I've got to look something up because um so this is another former regulator Cliff Bilo. Where is that? He's the one here in New Hampshire who wrote the first initial net metering law here in New Hampshire. And he says that even then, there was this intuition,
所以你在坑我，因为我没有。我在坑你。是的，我在屋顶上安装太阳能电池板让你花钱了。怎么回事，萨姆？怎么回事，萨姆？除了问题在于我们并不是百分之百确定那是真的。等一下。我得查点东西，因为……所以这是另一位前监管机构克里夫·比洛。那是在哪里？他是新罕布什尔州这里撰写了新罕布什尔州最初的净计量电价法律的人。他说，即便在当时，也有这样一种直觉。
like this feeling that maybe there were actually benefits to solar. So the feeling was solar might be higher than average and value, and I think the evidence has proven that out over the years that solar tends to produce at higher than average price hours. So Cliff Bilo is literally saying the exact opposite thing from Michael Harrington.
就像一种感觉，也许太阳能实际上是有好处的。所以这种感觉是太阳能的价值可能高于平均水平，我认为多年来的证据已经证明了这一点，即太阳能往往在高于平均价格的小时内发电。所以克里夫·比洛所说的话与迈克尔·哈灵顿的说法完全相反。
He's saying that me putting solarony Solar and Payons on my roof actually saves you guys money. Okay, well this is a pickle. I don't know if I believe him. I don't think it's gonna save enough money. All right, so let's first maybe dig into why it might be. Even though we pay the same amount for every unit of energy on our electric bills,
他说我在屋顶上安装太阳能电池板实际上为你们省了钱。好吧，这真是个棘手的情况。我不知道我是否相信他。我不认为这能省下足够的钱。好吧，让我们首先探讨一下为什么会这样。尽管我们在电费账单上为每一单位能量支付相同的金额。
all electrons are not created equal. In reality, every five minutes, there's a new auction for energy. of energy on our electric bills, all electrons are not created equal. In reality, every five minutes, there's a new option for energy. So every five minutes, we've got a new price for energy. When demand is low, prices are low, and they can actually go negative, like power plants will pay us so that they don't have to shut down, usually that's at night. And when demand is high, prices can be insane, like a hundred times higher than normal.
并非所有的电子都是生来平等的。实际上，每隔五分钟就会有一场新的能源拍卖。电费账单上的能量，并非所有的电子都是生来平等的。实际上，每隔五分钟就会有一场新的能源选择。所以每五分钟，我们就会有一个新的能源价格。当需求低时，价格低，它们甚至可以变成负数，比如发电厂会付钱给我们，这样他们就不必停机，通常那是在夜间。而当需求高时，价格可能会疯狂，比正常情况高出一百倍。
And again, the utilities take all of those costs, they average them all out, and they divide them by their customers. So the thing is, solar panels are producing at times of day that's really high value. Sunny, hot, those are usually the times where electricity is expensive, and that's when you're producing solar power.
同样，公用事业公司将所有这些成本加起来，算出平均值，然后分摊给他们的客户。所以关键在于，太阳能电池板在一天中价值极高的时间段发电。晴朗、炎热，这些通常是电力昂贵的时候，而这正是你产生太阳能电力的时候。
And so by feeding back into the grid, we're cutting usage so much that it lowers the price during those peak times. Exactly. And so cliff below is arguing these people are actually, you know, even though they're getting paid more than a regular power plant, they're actually getting paid less than the energy's worth. And that means that there's savings for every solar panel you put on the grid. I would admit, but that's only true up until a certain point, right?
因此，通过向电网回馈电力，我们极大地减少了使用量，从而降低了高峰时期的价格。完全正确。所以克里夫·比洛在争辩说，这些人实际上，你知道的，尽管他们得到的报酬比普通发电厂多，但他们实际上得到的报酬比能源的价值要少。这意味着你加到电网上的每一块太阳能电池板都能节省成本。我承认，但这只在一定程度上成立，对吧？
I mean, if you suddenly tip it and it goes from 20% of the population on solar panel to 50 to 70, then I'm sorry Cliff, your math doesn't work out. That is exactly right. You should go work for MIT. So people do have ideas about how to solve all of this, which we can talk about, or we could not. Give us one. Give us your favorite. All right, well, the most interesting to me
我的意思是，如果你突然让它倾斜，从20%的人口使用太阳能电池板变成50%到70%，那么很抱歉，克里夫，你的数学行不通了。完全正确。你应该去麻省理工学院工作。所以人们确实有关于如何解决所有这些问题的想法，我们可以讨论，或者我们也可以不讨论。给我们一个。给我们你最喜欢的。好吧，对我来说最有趣的是。
is from a guy called Don Creese. Do you think that the way that we pay for electricity is just dumb? It's a leading question. Yes. we pay for electricity is just dumb. It's a leading question. Yes, it is clearly inappropriate in today's technological age to continue to charge people the same price for electricity, 24.7, when the cost of providing people with electricity varies sometimes by orders of magnitude,
来自一个叫唐·克里斯的人。你觉得我们支付电费的方式很蠢吗？这是一个引导性问题。是的。我们支付电费的方式很蠢。这是一个引导性问题。是的，在当今的技术时代，继续全天候24/7向人们收取相同的电价显然是不合适的，而提供电力的成本有时会有几个数量级的差异。
depending on the time of day and the time of year and the grid conditions that apply. So is it not then by extension also kind of dumb to not vary the price that we're paying customers who are generating solar power from their roofs? I agree with that as well. Don is the state's consumer advocate. His job is to watch out for people who pay electric bills. So basically he's supposed to be keeping costs down and looking out for the little guy.
取决于一天中的时间和一年中的时间以及适用的电网条件。那么，从引申意义上讲，不改变我们向在屋顶上产生太阳能的客户支付的价格，难道不是也有点愚蠢吗？我也同意这一点。唐是该州的消费者权益倡导者。他的工作是照顾支付电费的人。所以基本上他应该负责控制成本并照顾小人物。
It simply isn't fair to take a retired schoolteacher living on a fixed income in Manchester and force that customer to pay subsidies to a wealthy hedge fund manager living in Bedford, who has a MacManchon that's covered in solar panels. Is there some actual retired school teacher and manchester and some actual hedge fund manager in Bedford because Michael Harrington gave me the exact same analogy?
把一个住在曼彻斯特靠固定收入生活的退休学校教师拿来，强迫该客户向一个住在贝德福德的富裕对冲基金经理支付补贴，而那个经理住着一座贴满太阳能电池板的豪宅，这简直太不公平了。曼彻斯特真的有某个退休学校教师，贝德福德真的有某个对冲基金经理吗？因为迈克尔·哈灵顿给了我一模一样的类比。
Not that I'm aware of. They're totally is. Where are those people? But anyway, I mean, Don Crease also thinks that this cost-shifting thing is a problem. And so this is what Don Crease wants to do. It's called a time of use rate. As in, you get paid more if your solar is going during those high price times, like later in the afternoon, but you also pay more if you're using more energy in the afternoon. And so to make this really simple, every day there'd be a
据我所知没有。他们绝对有。那些人在哪里？但无论如何，我的意思是，唐·克里斯也认为这种成本转移是一个问题。所以这就是唐·克里斯想做的。这叫做分时电价。也就是说，如果你的太阳能在那些高价时段（比如下午晚些时候）运行，你会得到更多的报酬，但如果你在下午使用更多的能量，你也要付更多的钱。为了使这变得非常简单，每天都会有一个。
different price, a higher price between 2 PM and 8 PM, which is when electricity is pricier. between 2PM and 8PM, which is when electricity is pricier. And this is cracking open the door to a radically different way to pay for energy. Instead of abiding by this crazy illusion that every electron is worth the same amount, it's acknowledging that when demand is high, electricity gets expensive, and maybe we should let people know that.
不同的价格，在下午2点到晚上8点之间价格更高，这时候电力更贵。在下午2点到晚上8点之间，这时候电力更贵。这为支付能源费用开辟了一种截然不同的方式。它没有遵守“每个电子价值都相同”这种疯狂的错觉，而是承认当需求高时，电力变得昂贵，也许我们应该让人们知道这一点。
I think that we can provide that more frequently updated information to consumers. So this is Jessica Transick. She's a professor of energy studies at MIT. I think that that should be possible, yeah. But she wants to take it even a step farther. Remember, there is constantly a new price for electricity every five minutes, and she thinks we should have a display in our houses that says, here's the price of energy right now. Like something that literally follows,
我认为我们可以向消费者提供更频繁更新的信息。所以这是杰西卡·特兰西克。她是麻省理工学院能源研究教授。我认为那是可能的，是的。但她想把事情推得更远。记住，每隔五分钟就会有一个持续的新电力价格，她认为我们应该在家里有一个显示屏，上面写着：这就是现在的能源价格。就像某种实际上遵循的东西。
like the five minute, every five minutes, the market clears, you get a new price. Well, maybe hourly, you know, I think five minutes, five minutes might be a bit too much, but hourly. So if you ever find a utility that wants to do that, I'm ready to sign up, I'll be in the pilot. I think that'll be fun. Okay, great. I'll let you know. I'll let you know. Now, see, I actually find that really interesting because I had no idea that it varied at all
就像五分钟，每五分钟，市场出清，你就会得到一个新的价格。嗯，也许按小时，你知道的，我认为五分钟，五分钟可能有点太多了，但按小时。所以如果你能找到一家想要这样做的公用事业公司，我准备报名，我将参加试点。我觉得那会很有趣。好的，太好了。我会告诉你。我会告诉你。现在，看，我其实觉得这真的很有趣，因为我根本不知道它会有所不同。
and it varies wildly. And, you know, I think twice about turning the light switch on if there was a flashing red high price alert or something. Yes, right. Now, there are some really important caveats to this approach. For one, rolling out new meters everywhere would be expensive, and this would be a very big,
而且它的变化非常剧烈。而且，你知道的，如果有一个闪烁的红色高价警报或类似的东西，我会三思而后行，决定是否打开电灯开关。是的，对的。现在，这种方法有一些非常重要的注意事项。首先，到处推广新电表将是昂贵的，这将是一个非常大。
maybe very difficult change in the way utilities operate. But for two, the markets can be brutal. There are prices that can go up like a hundred times the average, which is crazy. And that's why even Jessica Transick thinks that they should have a cap
这可能是公用事业运作方式的一个非常困难的改变。但其次，市场可能是残酷的。有些价格可以上涨到平均水平的一百倍左右，这太疯狂了。这就是为什么连杰西卡·特兰西克都认为他们应该设置上限。
and why Don Crease wants this sort of D-clawed version of that, which is like a slightly more expensive period from 2 to 8 p.m. versus really following the markets. But they both think that it's time we looked from 2 to 8 p.m. versus really following the markets. But they both think that it's time we looked at redesigning the way our electricity is metered
这也是为什么唐·克里斯想要这种被拔掉利爪的版本，也就是下午2点到8点这段时间稍微贵一点，而不是真正紧跟市场。但他们都认为现在是时候考虑了。从下午2点到8点，而不是真正紧跟市场。但他们都认为现在是时候考虑重新设计我们的电表计费方式了。
because solar has made everything more complicated. Here's Don Creese. Well, you know how net metering started? There was that architect guy and... And strong. Yeah. Did you actually talk to him? I spent a day with him. Really? So you know that like he? That's been a day with him. Really?
因为太阳能让一切都变得更加复杂。这是唐·克里斯。好吧，你知道净计量电价是怎么开始的吗？当时有那个建筑师和……还有斯特朗。是的。你真的跟谈过吗？我跟他待了一天。真的吗？所以你知道他只是……跟待了一天。真的吗？
So you know that he just did it without asking anybody's permission. Just like he didn't know. I want to see if my meter is going to run backwards. If I just wire my building up and attach it to the Boston Edison grid, I want to see what happens. I mean, it was right. But the fact is that it wasn't like the commission on
所以你知道他只是没有征求任何人的许可就做了。就像他不知道一样。我想看看我的电表会不会倒转。如果我只是把我的建筑布线并连接到波士顿爱迪生电网，我想看看会发生什么。我的意思是，那是对的。但事实是，并不像是委员会。
uniform state laws got together and said, let's design a net metering statute that will promote the development of distributed generation in this really logical, rigorous way. No, it just happened by accident. And now it's everywhere. And so it is high time for everybody to take a look and see what a rational, well-designed bit of public policy would be. that a public policy would be. Or maybe we'll just go back to building by the light bulb. Let's do it. I'm going to reduce my number of light bulbs.
统一州法开会并说，让我们设计一个净计量电价法规，以这种非常合乎逻辑、严格的方式促进分布式发电的发展。不，这只是偶然发生的。现在它到处都是。所以现在正是每个人都来看看什么是理性的、精心设计的公共政策的好时机。公共政策会是什么样的。或者也许我们将回到按灯泡收费的老路。让我们这么做吧。我要减少我的灯泡数量。
I can handle that. Be very cheap. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sam Evans Brown and Logan Shannon, with help from Maureen McMurray, Taylor Quimby, Jimmy Gutierrez, and Molly Donahue. A longer version of the story aired on the podcast outside in from New Hampshire Public Radio. Go listen to some of their other episodes, they're great, they do nerd stuff just like we do and they make it really fun, you're gonna like it. Special thanks this week to Bob Johnstone who wrote the book, Switting to Solar and Haskell, Whirlin. You can see pictures of that infamous first grid-tied solar apartment building at our website, 9-9-PI, dot work. Music this week was from Jazaar, Jason Leonard, Blue Dot Sessions, Pottington Bear, Okakumi,
我能搞定那个。会非常便宜。“99%隐形”本周由萨姆·埃文斯·布朗和洛根·香农制作，莫琳·麦克默里、泰勒·奎姆比、吉米·古铁雷斯和莫莉·多诺霍提供了帮助。该故事的加长版在新罕布什尔公共广播电台的播客节目《外在》中播出。去听听他们的其他节目，它们很棒，他们像我们一样做书呆子气的事情，而且他们让它变得非常有趣，你会喜欢的。本周特别鸣谢鲍勃·约翰斯通，他写了《转向太阳能》一书，以及哈斯克尔·沃林。你可以在我们的网站 9-9-PI 点工作（org）上看到那个臭名昭著的第一座并网太阳能公寓楼的照片。本周的音乐来自贾扎尔、杰森·伦纳德、蓝点之声、波廷顿熊、奥卡库米。
and Sean Rial. The outside-in theme music is by Break Master Cylinder. 99% of visible is Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Kurt Colstad, Taren Masa, Katie Mingle, Sean Rial, Avery Troll from Munch's Sharif Yousif, and me Roman Mars. This piece was edited for our use by Katie and Mixed by Sharif. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can find this show in joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or we're on Instagram, Tumblr, and
和肖恩·里亚尔。《外在》的主题音乐由突破魔方制作。“99%隐形”的成员包括德兰尼·霍尔、埃姆内特·菲茨杰拉德、库尔特·科尔斯塔德、塔伦·马萨、凯蒂·明格、肖恩·里亚尔、阿弗里·托尔、芒奇斯、谢里夫·优素福以及我罗曼·马尔斯。这篇文章经过凯蒂的编辑供我们使用，并由谢里夫混音。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心无线电街。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @我（Roman Mars）和 @节目（99PI），或者我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 上。
have a nice subreddit too. But we release at least two articles about design and architecture every week on our website. That's 99io.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也有一个不错的小版块（subreddit）。但我们在网站上每周至少发布两篇关于设计和建筑的文章。网址是 99io.org。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。